well a huge percentage of what you hear
on TV these days centers on the perils
of Russia Russia attacked our democracy
Russia corrupted our election Putin is
declared war Russia is our greatest
threat that's the Democratic Party and
their PR department in the American
media have been telling us for more than
a year
no one's defending Russia but is this
true let's play game and you can decide
we'll describe actions by a hostile
foreign power and you guess whether it's
Russia or China get a pen ready first
the FBI director said this country uses
students and professors at American
universities as spies this problem is so
widespread that almost every FBI field
office is dealing with it
Russia nope China China has 350,000
students in the u.s. some of whom
apparently are intelligence agents next
question this country reportedly hacked
the Office of Personnel Management
giving it access to millions of federal
personnel records which allows its spy
agency to locate espionage targets this
country also hacked the FDIC and a
number of other government agencies and
departments Russia no China this a
company from this country has
effectively taken over an entire u.s.
territory bloomberg reported last week
and a massive state-sponsored gambling
operation now essentially runs the
island of saipan which used to be ours
Russia no China once again question for
this country will soon overtake the US
as the world's largest economy if it has
not already Russia
please it's hilarious Russia's
third-world compared to yes China this
country has killed tens of thousands of
Americans by manufacturing and exporting
fentanyl the deadliest narcotic known to
man Russia may have maintained fake
twitter accounts but actually China did
that finally this country demands that
American companies censor their products
movies media websites in order not to
offend the corrupt corrupt oligarchy
that runs their police state amazingly
American companies obediently comply
with these orders because they're afraid
not to is it Russia their kowtow to that
mean old Putin of course not it's China
so tell us which country strikes you as
a bigger threat to America nygma is the
author of Chinese girl in the ghetto
former deputy director of the committee
for American sovereignty approach from
super PAC and she joins us tonight
thanks for coming up thank you so much
so look I mean they're a couple levels
one I think China is a threat
it's the rise of China is a threat to
our place in the world but compared to
Russia
is there really a comparison well you
know let's recall that a few years ago
Senator John McCain who said that Russia
really is just a gas station
masquerading as a country so you know
you don't need to take that literally
but I think any sane person would look
at China's economy look at the
trajectory of their eyes and understand
that China actually poses a much more
serious long-term strategic threat to
America's place in the world but we
don't even have to look at that on such
a broad scale I think we just need to
look back 20 years the last time we had
a serious foreign influence
campaign scandal in this country was
during the Clinton era when you know the
Democratic National Committee was forced
to give back nearly three million
dollars of foreign money and we know
that Russian money and and we know that
you know during that scandal there was
actually a lot of Chinese money involved
money from the communist government or
people affiliated with the Chinese
government and there was money from
elsewhere in Asia too but but I mean
that was actually real money that had to
be given back that's far we haven't seen
anything like that in the current Russia
investigation so is it possible that if
you want to know who has power you just
ask who does nobody criticize everyone
can criticize Russia there are no
repercussions as a single person in
Hollywood or in finance and Verte
criticize China doesn't it kind of tell
you how beholden we are to China what a
threat they actually are that nobody
ever says anything well I mean I think
some people have criticized China when
it was popular to do so I mean let's
remember seven years in Tibet done by
Brad Pitt it was popular back then to
Curtis did that get made today I don't
know I mean you know Hollywood hasn't
come and asked me for my opinion on the
even get a movie role
well yeah there you go but what we do
know is that a lot of these Hollywood
people like to do things that are
popular in these days that is popular to
criticize Donald Trump it is popular to
question the legitimacy of his electoral
victory a lot of the people who are
obsessed with the Russia investigation
people from the fake news media what
they really want to do is essentially
just to sort of bring out anything that
makes the current president legit just
bought I mean look I think it's okay to
criticize the president I've criticized
many presidents and met really meant it
but if you care about the country you
have to think soberly about what threats
it faces yes and if you're telling the
public that Russia's the biggest threat
America faces you're either lying or
stupid well or you could be both right
you know what we do know is yes you
could do you know is that while we've
been obsessing over this Russia
investigation we've actually ignores
some really weighty issues not just
China but China being one of them one of
the most weighty issues among them no
it's a really good point there's a huge
cost as Lee Smith is you're saying
there's a big cost of this stuff thank
you for that